>>Turner: All right,
June, let's get a hug.
>>Cantor: The driver for
learning is the social connection.
Activating a child's
cognitive skills begins
with activating their
social connectedness.
>>Children in this school are starting
the day with an adult saying to them,
"I see you, I know you, I'm connecting
with you, and you're important to me."
>>Turner: We start each day by
greeting every kid at the door.
>>Good morning, Douglas.
>>Douglas: You look pretty, Miss Turner!
>>Turner: Thank you, baby.
>>Every classroom does
some variation of would you
like a high-five, handshake, or hug?
Essentially, it's "What
greeting would you like?"
>>Turner: Ho you doing, handsome?
>>Child: Good.
>>Cantor: There is a great deal of
cultural sensitivity and empowerment
for children to say, "Here
is how I want to greet you."
>>Turner: High-five, handshake or hug?
You got your hair done?
>>Molly: Hug.
>>Turner: Good morning,
Molly. You got your hair done?
Let me see, turn around.
I love it. All right, we gonna
have a good day today? All right.
>>High-give, handshake or hug?
>>During that time, I'm just
trying to connect with them,
help them from their transition from
home to school and just kind of--
it's like a pulse check
to see where they are.
>>Oh! I knew you wanted a hug.
Arrrgh! How you feeling today, sir?
>>Child: Good.
>>Turner: Are we going to have
a good day? Look in my eyes.
>>Do they look escalated, do they
look triggered, do they look upset?
So, this is a way for me to see, okay,
who needs to be where, how can I help,
how can I be of assistance to start
their day off most effectively?
>>Turner: Good morning,
Ariella! How you doing today?
>>I'm being very intentional about
my interactions with students, right?
So, it's not just I'm in the
back of the room, "Hey, come in."
No, I'm making connection with them.
I'm-- have eye contact with them.
I'm checking in on how they're doing,
I'm checking to make sure they're okay.
>>Good morning, friends.
>>Children: Good morning, friends.
>>Turner: I think the impact
is deep relationships.
I get to know my students,
I get to check in with them.
I get to find out something about them,
they get to find out something about me.
We get to make a connection and that
starts with the greeting at the door.
>>All right, come on in.
>>Cantor: So, a child is walking in
the door feeling cared for, empowered
and encouraged, and that teacher is
focusing in on who that child is,
and that's how the day starts.